[Music]
over the years I've had great fun being
rude about vegetarians but today I'm
joining them I put together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner packed with
amazing tastes textures and full-on
flavor without a bit of meat in sight I
guarantee My ultimate vegetarian food
will have even the most committed
Carnival drooling and begging for more
first up a real treat of a meat-free
breakfast pear and crunchy granola
muffins for the perfect vegetarian lunch
crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes halloumi cheese doesn't look
that tasty but once you've got color on
it it's really delicious and my youngest
daughter Tilly joins me in the kitchen
to make a scrummy three-course veggie
dinner that's my guilty pleasure is it
really courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto and for put white chocolate and
lime mousse with crushed raspberries wow
that looks really cool these are my
ultimate vegetarian recipes breakfast
lunch and dinner
first the perfect morning treat for
vegetarians and carnivores alike pear
and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
muffin bean bags the flour and the
baking powder in a nice touch of
cinnamon
cinnamon muffins goes brilliantly pinch
of salt that's really important for the
sort of overall flavor you don't want
the muffin to be too sweet muscovado
sugar that's a refined brown sugar
really rich and somewhat spicy it goes
brilliantly inside the muffin and then
my crispy granola
now we're gonna put half of this in now
and say the other half just sprinkle on
top of the muffin give that a really
good mix
in the center I have some fresh pear top
and tail of the pears really important
to peel I think worse when you're trying
to enjoy that muffin and you're
negotiating with a big sliver
skin of pear
slice them around the core
sides
a slice them nice and thinly
generally muffins contain around half
the fat and sugar of cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet
two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture
start folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty little beasts don't
overwork your muffin mixture you want
that mixture to become nice and relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
that's right
and your little cups
and Spoon in that mixture
two-thirds full
one nice generous spoon
and you can tell the mix is right
because you've got that even
distribution of the pear running from
the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you've got this dual texture
spicy pear and this nice crunchy topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more luxurious now into the oven at
180 for 25 minutes
uses
they smell delicious
got that nice crispy top just get them
out and let them cool down
and I don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when I'm having muffins like that
nice
smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that is a Vegetarian Delight useful
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
first here's a more in-depth look at the
key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner I'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in Italian
cuisine but is widely believed that the
Spaniards introduced it to Northern
Italy back in the Middle Ages there are
three main types Arborio kanaroli and
violoni
their ability to absorb liquid and
flavor whilst releasing lots of starch
is what makes risotto uniquely delicious
and anxious
a tasty creamy and inexpensive way to
satisfy lots of tummies without a morsel
of meat in sight
[Music]
the Deep dramatic red color of sweet
earthy beetroot makes it difficult to
outdo in terms of all-round culinary
impact
but early forms of this humble room veg
were carrot shapes and favored for their
medicinal rather than their cooking
merits today there is a veritable
rainbow of beetroot types to be enjoyed
pickled in soups grated into cakes or
even simply roasted which is how I'll be
using mine in my amazing vegetarian main
course risotto
[Music]
firm springy salty cheese with its roots
firmly in Cyprus and Greece the better
Lumi is made from sheep's milk rich in
vitamins and essential nutrients is
thought to promote longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge and its high
melting point makes it brilliantly
adaptable perfect for grilling barbecue
and frying I'll be championing this
texture lending Marvel for my yummy
vegetarian lunch dish of halloumi
courgette and Herb cakes
[Music]
as a chef I'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because I know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch I got a couple of fantastic
recipes
lightly fried my delicious Lumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
these Church matters are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes Vine
tomatoes are good or even just big
normal plum tomatoes lay the tomatoes on
the tray
and he's going to the oven for about 90
minutes
you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
and the salt and sugar combined speeds
up the drying process because you want
that nice chewy texture and then you get
these little time flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your Tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees C and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
fill the carrots
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keeping it
all grated the same put that into a
sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water in the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this it'll make
your little patties non-friable because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now if you wait until you've
cooked them it'll be too late to adjust
the seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball shape
them it's like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot boss and wait for that I'll
get the dressing ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
season with a Sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
because that's sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done I can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
with my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
Watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
foreign s
Watercress and shallot they're
brilliantly well together
looks so dainty when you open up these
little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious little drizzle of age pulse
mint vinegar gives that tartness to the
watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice
but that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
would none of the meat
when I was growing up my mum was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and two veg and
the veg definitely played a bit past but
the more attention you pay to cooking
vegetables the more you realize they can
easily take Center Stage for all the
flavor we're none of the flesh here's my
ultimate vegetarian dinner
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main I'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and Thyme risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in Little Bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so what kind of cream is that in there
dad that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark
um I love white and milk what's yours I
absolutely love milk chocolate
oh my guilty pleasure is it really here
we go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your Jumper's white so you won't
spot it yeah I've got a nice little snap
for later
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
mmm it smells really good the lime gives
it a really nice zinginess you're
absolutely right next add to the melted
chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter have a
little taste
mmm
nice yeah the lime gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse I need some for my tummy no come
on chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's gonna be really tough
so we'll take it in turns 30 seconds
each okay you go first
second's gone
come on Tilly see seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change exit
hold the ball right no no way
[Music]
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
you start tipping our sugar in slowly
good deal
it's still not very happy in there so
contentious whipped egg whites will make
our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need to crush some raspberries please
with some fresh mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom though
crushed raspberry delicious now I'm
going to set that in the fridge if you
can use the can I open the door please
our yummy white chocolate mousse will
take at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our Mediterranean inspired
vegetarian starter griddle courgette
Ricotta and mint bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
[Music]
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty tepata with dollops
of minty Ricotta and top with your
seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto I want to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important
to have your stock gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock yeah because
you can't have different stocks if it's
for a vegetarian okay
I made that mistake once putting beef
stock in the vegetarian soup did you no
I didn't Matilda
I'm positive I'm joking
fly off the time how nice is that smell
s rice in
this is Arborio rice it's a perfect rice
for risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
let's go with our deep red beetroot
theme I'm adding red wine followed by
the first Ladle of stock to get things
started now we're off wow it's giving it
a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
sock is reducing down and the rice is
sucking it in that's right so the rice
is actually getting nice and plump one
of risotto is live when it's like this
now we can't stop cooking it we have to
cook it all the way okay ready for the
next ladle
good girl here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
eight words
killed him brought them a little bit of
salt and sugar yeah and a little bit of
aged bathroom vinegar in there roasted
them I'm a great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
now that
that's where you want to be now look at
that nice glossy textured rice so
beetroot I want you to put two-thirds of
the beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there the butter
gives the risotto a really nice gloss
look at that beautiful
come down let it come down first
and then after Daddy
okay there you go good wonderful shaking
risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the beat
room on top
[Music]
and some extra virgin olive oil
that I'll pick up the bruschetta you
take that to the table okay
let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries
a delicious non-meat feast that will
have vegetarians and carnivores fighting
for seconds tonight is vegetarian nights
Megan how is it really tasting I love it
I really like making the risotto and we
had fun
so where's Holly
it's not very nice I hope your ears
cheers everybody no meat vegetarian
vegetarians
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food I think
every home cooked needs recipes that
don't just taste delicious but satisfy
the soul too the type of food that wraps
his arms around you and gives you big
hugs so when you want to give your
family and friends a big serving of Love
here's my ultimate comfort food dish is
guaranteed to make you feel cozy even on
the coldest of days
first up a breakfast that will bring you
a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast for lunch I'm pulling
out all the stops with a fantastic Twist
on one of Britain's favorite comfort
dishes ginger beer battered fish with
chili minted mushy peas It's Gonna Do It
do it properly for dinner my youngest
daughter Tilly is in the kitchen and we
share the secret ingredient in every
comfort food dish happy memories did you
like to help Nan make your hot pot when
she made them for you always sausage hot
pot with beetroot and potato gratins on
the menu for dessert spiced apple
compots silly we're on for a treat this
is my ultimate comfort food breakfast
lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on it I used to
sneak a couple of sugar lumps from cafes
and put them in my porridge without him
watching these days my porridge has much
more flavor than just salt it's packed
with fruit nuts and spices add vanilla
seeds to porridge oats or oatmeal really
important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible I quite like making
this up week at a time and Jack
absolutely loves it now whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pot in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
I'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge and then a couple of
minutes before you go to bake it add
your cream
into your dish
it looks quite liquid but by the time it
bakes has this really nice rich crust on
top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful literally for three to four
minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be Scottish
because it's perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast it's Rich it's
Sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
[Music]
next I'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food I crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
My ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage I grew up on the classic British
Banger made with ground pork salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and I'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch I'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in Southeast Asian
cooking
grape seeds made from those yellow
flowering crops this has the lowest
saturated fat content of any oil and has
a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
cheap or rounder with a neutral flavor
is vegetable oil which is the blend of
oils like corn soybean and sunflower
[Music]
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from China but today in
Britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the UK
are Braven and Gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp Bramley which I'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food multimet
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas I've loved it ever since I was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks
for my Ultimate Fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of Ginger to go with it
chili minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that'll keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic that the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour I want a bit of heat in the batter
so a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then two teaspoons of baking powder
this almost lightens the lobe of the
batter now ginger beer it gives that
batter the sort of unique spicy
individual flavor it's delicious for the
fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
Sheen give that a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
its magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish
I was going slightly firm
perfect for frying start by coating the
fish in flour seasoned with pepper hats
that nice and dry into your hands so you
haven't got any excess flour the flour
stops the batter from running off the
fish I'm just gonna check to see if my
oil's ready by putting a little touch of
batter into the fryer you see it
bubbling straight to the very top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist your pan
that stops IT from sticking at the
bottom oil should be gently sort of
bubbling away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish fry the fish for three to five
minutes gently turning halfway through
once the batter's golden and crisp it's
ready look they look stunning it's like
these big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured Cod leave the fish to rest on
the kitchen towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chili
minted mushy peas
now how much your peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
and a nice
knob of butter into the pan
shallot finely chopped that adds a bit
of sweetness to the peas shots into the
pan
chili
Pizza Delicious when you eat peas and
they're slightly spicy they're even
better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infused
with their perfect partner fresh mint
stalks on all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the piece I've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
I love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
Crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed delicious peas
those peas it's incredible
chopped mint
chili minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
if you're going to do it
do it properly
oh
[Music]
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic and the best way to
eat this is with Crispy buttered saute
potatoes cooked with garlic Rosemary and
Thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells from the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
I love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and I hope it will always remind my kids
of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood as my
youngest daughter Tilly
[Music]
food dinner is a stunning sausage Hot
Pot which will serve with a gorgeous
potato and beetroot gratin
now I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
I just love having them
being sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them all and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today school was good thanks we
got to go out and make snowmen sausages
in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
darling
[Music]
see
now
want you to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
now
sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little butter okay into the pan
stuff
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so they'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor
smells nice mushrooms in give them a
nice little stir did you like to help
them make your hot pot when she made
them for you I used to always help now
make the hot pot always now my mum would
never have used this but A's balsamic
vinegar brings out the flavor of the
onions right now look at her onions look
beautiful caramelized the vinegar has
given that nice sort of gloss I'm gonna
put my sausages back in here now from
there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven 170 in
the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly sliced potatoes and
cook beetroot
foreign
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes and
pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
sour
CE thanks for the warning
blew my head off they're incredibly
acidic okay and you need to cook them
those wonderful red apples you've got
are called Bray Burns what other apples
you know cream ones what are they called
um
the green ones another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no Pink Lady apple no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apple that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
the place is quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out Dan so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
and take
a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the color of the apples let's put
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Daddy
right egg whites are in they're great
they're separate off your good eye
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
should go
[Music]
please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff Pig so you lift them
up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
foreign
whips so much quicker
yeah
nice
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree
and you mix that in nice and carefully
it says like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep good girl
hmm silly we're on for a treat open up
the Piping Bag
now to the end
now you could spoon this in I don't want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern lemon on top
fridge the beetroot and potato gratin is
that lovely that's lovely sausages
finished with the flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots
ever Tilly that looks amazing
well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple compot
food with guaranteed feel-good Factor
mommy Jack Holly Megan
doesn't it
smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorites so
tasty I love it this is so good I love
the mushrooms as well that is so nice
and so simple when I was your age guys
Nanny was making this for me in those
days the sausages weren't as fat you
would ride to school on dinosaurs
excuse me I'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
foreign